foreign
brilliant well uh cure to everyone
um I won't be doing a prayer today or a
karakia um I don't don't have one in
front of me uh but we will either be
doing one or the other in the future
um another conversation that I need to
be having with cancer so um apologies
for that
uh let's let's get into it so the first
is the inaugural council meeting
um which I hereby declare is now open
um I don't believe we have any apologies
could be corrected no no apologies
perfect
right first agenda item second agenda
item should I say
uh so pursuant to a conversation
um with with the councilors and a
decision made
I have decided that we will table this
issue until the next council meeting
which will be in December the only so
there will still there will be no no
discussion the only bit I might point
out is that I will be exercising my
rights
um under the live Government Act to
appoint uh councilor Stuart maxinel as
my Deputy Mia
other than that the rest of the report
will be tabled for the next council
meeting
your worship um pursuant to the
requirements of the the statutory
requirements for the inaugural meeting
um I would move for the purposes uh the
pending production of a further report
from the chief executive there shall be
no committees established in the interim
all matters shall be considered by the
full Council
thank you that for that um councilor
hovel yes I totally agreed so there'll
be no no committees formed until the
next meeting and all matters will come
to full Council in the interim
uh let's take into two that motion
uh councilor Dixon would you like to
speak to that
and I believe that motion has passed all
those in favor all those in favor say
aye
and the motion has passed
sorry guys just getting used to this
meeting schedule um so if I could get a
mover for this motion
one's a bit slow I'll move that the
recommendation be accepted
and a second call so counselor so uh
motion mover uh councilor hotel and
secondary councilor McDonald
and all those in favor please say aye
and the motion has been carried
standing orders
I believe that they're uh maybe some
discussion on this one so if we have a
mover of the motion
uh councilor short mcdonell
uh did you want to speak on standing
orders at all
no uh and a second
uh councilor John Garden
do we have any discussion any further
points
you worship these two matters I wish to
raise really for clarification and the
first is in relation to section 13.1
and that deals with members rights to
attend bentings
and and it's something I think the chief
executive can help with any member of
the council is able to attend any
meeting of the local Authority and I'm
just seeking some clarification as to uh
members of the full Council whether they
are able to attend
meetings of the matara community board
and be present during
um
public excluded portions without having
any special resolution required by the
community board so that's a paragraph
13.1
as the TV you have could speak to that
when he's ready
through your worship and I believe the
answer is yes but I would like to just
double check on the definition of a
local Authority member and my off the
top
interpretation would that it would
include an elected so if you're
attending a meeting of the community
board as a local Authority member who
has as of right is allowed to remain in
committee unless lawfully excluded my
off the cuff assessment is at elected
councilors who have occasion to attend a
community board meeting and if that
meeting is conducting in committee
business
subject to reading interpretation that
goes against that my um
belief is that the elected member is
entitled to remain and does not need to
see express permission from the chair
although it may well be courtesy to do
so
but I would qualify that with that
answer that without extra 10 minutes
just to quickly look up some definitions
to make sure that I'm absolutely correct
thank you the other matter relates to
section 20.7 dealing with conflicts of
interest
conflicts of interest apply directly or
indirectly so it could be a spouse or or
a partner with it's um uh financial gain
either directly or indirectly and what
standing orders 20.7 says is that
members with a financial interest should
physically withdraw themselves from the
table
um where we've got a public meeting and
if it's public excluded then they should
leave the room and
uh so if we're in a public meeting uh
standing orders merely say that you
should leave the table but you can stay
in the room
um and it's a matter in the next
paragraph for each individual to decide
um rather than we can't have a motion at
the table that declares someone to have
there so to me that suggests that the
role of the chief executive is to
highlight any particular issue but it is
for the individual member to decide
whether they have that conflict
foreign
absolutely correct councilor hovel uh it
is not
for uh any elective member to say uh you
have a conflict of interest interest and
you should remove yourself
they can advise the member they believe
they they may have a conflict of
interest they can seek advice and
Achieve executive But ultimately the
judgment is on the member him or herself
in relation to standing orders
um that's correct I will note however
that the auditor General's office
believes is best practice when it comes
to a pecuniary financial peculiary
interest that the member should actually
leave the room
um and I guess the reason for that is to
avoid any
possibility or suggestion that body
language is being used to influence an
outcome
is there any further matters on the
standing orders uh there's actually some
that I would like to point out through
the chief particular so in appendix 8
there's a number of points in here that
are missing the standing orders
references I know it's just a formality
but
um for instance in the second page here
action on previous resolutions it looks
like there's a half finished
standing order reference
yeah
um and and just all of the other ones
that are blank here do they have
standing orders um associated with them
or that are that are missing or are they
more summarizations of those individual
points
I would need to take some advice and let
you worship because uh this has been
produced by local government New Zealand
as a standard template and
um
I'm not sure why some of those
paragraphs that haven't been referenced
by the actual Clause within the standing
order itself so I would need to
take some advice on that and my
suggestion would be that if the
counselors of a mind to move move these
standing orders that they'd be done so
subject to any minor editorial Amendment
deemed necessary to give greater
understanding to how the appendices in
particular relate to the body of the
document
yes I would tend to agree and I think
that's in line with councilor hotels
um points there
um
was there any other discussion points
from from councilors out there
no
the other thing I just wanted to know
there was a removal of appendix 9 the
mayor's powers to adopt under support
under the ACT section 41A and removed
the appendix around workshops I was just
wondering if there was a reasoning
behind those or is that directly due to
this is in comparison to last year's
standing orders so last trainium
standing orders I was just under trying
to understand the removal of those
appendices
okay that's appendix appendix
ability was 9 and 11 and the old
standing orders which you should have a
book quickly
that may have been a templating
um difference as well
yes again Mr your worship
um that is this is an LG NZ template
that has been amended to reflect current
practice and
um any minor changes in the way in which
councils gather themselves again I
couldn't give you an authoritative
answer off the top you might hear about
why those appendix have been removed or
whether they are Incorporated elsewhere
in the document as we speak because
certainly the men the mere's powers
under Section 41A is referenced in the
Local Government Act in 2002 that's
where it refers to so whether that was
deemed to be
sufficiently
stand alone because there's some partly
standing orders relate directly to
either local government at 2002 or the
local government official information
and meetings act to 1987. so whether the
author of the new standing orders
thought that section 41A for example
which is in statute doesn't need to be a
separate dependency again I'd need to
talk to the authors to find that
clarification
I think to to counselor hoval's Point
um and also just some some errors and
templating
um moving it across I think that we
should uh amend the motion slightly
um so that we accept the
um
we accept the standing orders on the
basis of those those minor editorial
changes
um that obviously will be run past
councils as well um that we but we still
adopt these standing orders do I so I
have um I'm happy to move that motion do
I have a second before that motion
uh council is sure major now
um and then oh and
um it's so cool and then um So that
obviously I believe the order is takes
us back to
um the motion itself um so we do we have
a someone to move the motion is that
Amendment um councilor Stringer and
someone to second that
uh councilor John Garden and all those
in favor say aye
fantastic
understanding orders have been adopted
very it's
next up was the
uh generator number five Gore district
council code of conduct
find that but do we have
um someone to move that motion
this is to uh accept the the code of
conduct as it stands
uh moved by councilor hi Sid
and a seconder uh councilor uh Stringer
orders in favor please say aye
oh Mission has been moved
and then changing over to the chief
executive here for the general
explanations as part of the inaugural
council meeting
thank you worship yes under the uh
Clause 21 of schedule 7 the level
government eight I'm required to give
you a general explanation of relevant
statutes that affect local government so
for those in the audience that are
wondering
um about the necessity of this it is a
statute requirement and so I'll do my
best to
efficiently run through the various
statutes
and to give you an appreciation I should
also mention your worship that we have a
standing invitation from a local Law
Firm to provide a more detailed briefing
to councilors On All or some of these
enactments should the council wish to to
Avail themselves of that opportunity
so the Local Government Act
2002 is the first statute and of course
this is a statute that I will and the
council will be referring to on a very
regular basis throughout the term of
this particular Council it sets out
really your uh your powers
your obligations your roles and
responsibilities as an elective member
um and it's a very important statute it
does run to a fearsome size but the
council staff are there to highlight the
relevant Provisions that you need to be
taking cognizance of prior to making
your decision on a given matter
um but it does for elected members you
should familiar yourselves with uh
particularly decision-making
Provisions in the ACT uh the principles
of consultation uh your role as an
elected member the role of the chief
executive of the role of the mayor
they're all quite explicitly laid out in
that and
so for example to sit here that the
chief Executives the employer of Staff
the council employees the chief
executive
um and if everyone appreciates those
respective roles it generally makes for
a well streamlined and good functioning
Council
the other act mentioned here is a local
government official information and
meetings act it's a mouthful and uh
colloquially is referred to as leguma by
those in the trade it really governs and
so as it has two discrete arms like yes
you you would say all parts so the ACT
has very heavily anchored around the
principle of Freedom of Information and
information when requested should be
made available
and there are timelines for the
production of that information when
anyone from the public can request
there are legitimate reasons for
declining to release the information
and those reasons are laid out on page
what my page 12 of the report so they
cover such things as these absolute no
Christian reasons which is the
prejudicing the the maintenance of the
law or when someone's safety is
endangered there are another host of
reasons and most of a lot of these
sorry some of them are contentious some
of them are clear-cut so the protection
of privacy of people is a pretty
clear-cut example the maintenance of
professional legal privilege is also a
fairly clear-cut example where it's
permissible to withhold information
but there are others around carrying on
negotiations and this is an important
point to emphasize that sometimes it's
quite permissible and often is very
permissible to decline to release
information when negotiations are on
train
but once the negotiations are concluded
often the information then can be
released and invariably is and that it
applies to like so for example in
committee minutes governing such things
as tenders or other type of
negotiations once completed generally
speaking the information is released
so this is a very important part of the
of the operation the uh the
consideration of information requests as
a responsibility of the chief executive
and if a member of the public is
dissatisfied with the answer is entitled
to seek a review from the office of the
Ombudsman who then
um the Ombudsman requests and we must
deliver all the information to the
Ombudsman who follow an investigation
will make a ruling as to where the
information can be continued to be
withheld or whether there should be a
full or partial release
uh so the role of the Ombudsman off the
top of my head I think New Zealand was
the third country in the world to get to
the office of the Ombudsman goes back to
1975.
it's a Scandinavian term it was invented
by the ironically by I think Sweden and
when we talk about the least corrupt
countries in the world and the most
transparent processes New Zealand and
Denmark usually fight for for number one
spot and so the ombudsman's role as one
as a as a a gatekeeper it's a officer
appointed by Parliament and it's there
to investigate
um decisions administrative decisions of
the council and that's an important
point to emphasize the Ombudsman is
there not to disturb decisions made by a
democratically elected Council but its
decisions made by myself or officers of
council where someone could say there's
been some male Administration and those
decisions can be reviewed and directive
given by the office of the Ombudsman to
be fair most of the interface with this
Council has been the honest one would be
over refusal of release of official
information there's only been probably
two three four maybe in my time where
there has been a decision made by the
administration which has been the
subject of a complaint and then for a
review by the the ombudsman the leguma
also covers such things as access to
meetings order papers audit meetings at
meetings a lot of the stuff that's in
the standing orders is directly lifted
from
act
an important part to emphasize is the
counselors have qualified privilege
and it's not absolute privilege so it
should not in any form or imagination be
misconstrued with the Parliamentary
privilege which is absolute so the
um the qualified privilege just means
that
counselors who act with a firm belief in
without malice are protected but if it
is malicious and Reckless the qualified
privilege will not attach to the
incident and some liability could be um
be faced by the individual concern but
as I've said to previous councils if
elected members obey the the normal
rules of care to see Good Men as a
mutual trust and respect this type of
issue need not bother you at all
um
we also have the local Authority members
interest act and that this covers
pecuniary interests as a particularly
important for elective members that may
be contracting with the council now
again the key thing that will you'll
find when you read some of the
um publications of the office of yoga
General is that there's nothing wrong in
having a conflict of interest it's how
you manage that conflict which is the
most important thing
and so in this case there is a 25 000
threshold that's placed in the 1968 act
because it's painfully out of date uh
the financial thresholds have been that
they reflect 1968 world but uh despite
repeated urgings from a number of
commentators Parliament over the years
has not been inclined to update the ACT
so the the key thing with the
Contracting rule is that if you're
Contracting with the council you cannot
conduct more than twenty five thousand
dollars worth of business with the
council in a given year
otherwise you'll be in breach of the ACT
uh extensions to that limit can be given
by the office of the original but the
onus and the clear thing here is the
owners is on the elected member
to actually monitor the expenditure
levels of business transacted and to
apply for extension before the limit is
reached that's a very important point
um and then of course the participation
rule which means that you can't vote on
a matter in which you have a financial
interest and I think that's I hope
that's fairly well understood by elected
members
um
more contentious I guess uh where the
gray line is is non-pecuniary conflicts
of interest and generally you find the
smaller Community the more likely
non-pecuniary conflicts of interest
arise this is where you don't have a
financial interest but you may belong to
an organization or a club
or a school board whatever it might be
that has an issue before the council and
you have a divided loyalty because
you're loyalty your loyalty lies with
the council and also the the
organization that you may have
an office you may have you may hold an
office with and the higher the office
you hold in the other organization the
more conflict you have and again
generally speaking it's you've got a
conflict you can't do justice to either
you should remove yourself from the
debate
um
sorry the
coveted exemption so the local
government has been amendment to Local
Government Act which covers the local
government pecunery interest register
there's a separate report that appears
in the next section of the meeting
but this is an important provision that
came law just two days ago
and unlike in previous times where
elected members and a local Council
setting had the discretion as to whether
they would compile
um a register of their own personal
interest and all of that conflicts can
be managed this is now mandatory
and we've got till February until to
actually
compose a register of all elected
members interests it's quite expansive
and far-reaching previously the council
had a voluntary process where for
example just interests in the gore
District were mentioned or requested
this is now more expensive than that so
the register will be compiled and would
obviously there's a provision in that
act to actually appoint a registrar and
that's the subject of a separate report
in the agenda but the key emphasis there
is to ensure that you need to actually
participate and ultimately this will be
on a website for the public to peruse
some councils have done this for some
time on a voluntary basis but this is
now compulsory
um
now I never liked talking about some of
these acts but they have to so um we
have the serious Ford office act
um
which covers serious fraud
um now the the council does have a fraud
policy and it is an area of
some
Inquisition by annual audit uh the
council has never had any issues with
this area
but
the the CFO the serious full office
certainly investigates more serious
allegations of fraud including bribery
and Corruption
we also have the health and safety act
at health and safety act at work act
which is a mouthful that was the act
that was comprehensively
um over overhauled the previous Act was
uh 1992 it places
a heavy burden on
um
senior managers and the governance arm
of an entity
to look after the safety and the health
and well-being of their workers
the council does have a duty to in
respect of elected members our officers
under that and therefore you have
responsibilities under health and safety
a work act along with myself and Senior
managers
but as elected members you don't have
the liability that the chief executive
and the Senior Management staff do in
regard to any breach
so it's a very important part of our
work and the health and safety practices
of the council
monitored by our audit and risk
committee
harmful digital harmful digital
Communications act
2015. it's probably a
a regretful inclusion the statute book
that reflects the the modern digital
Communications and how that can come
from people that have
um a
proclivity to
send harmful messages on a consistent
basis
um
and there are 10 Communications
principles for guideline Communication
online
I don't think I'm sure that the lectin
members will conduct themselves in a
very professional courteous and
respectful manner
um
and but it's something we have to be
aware aware of because we do interface
with the digital media
um and therefore
um need to be weary of a person who's
like who could potentially be committing
an offense under this act
we also have the sections 99 105 and
105a of the Crimes Act
they really relate to
the notion that elected members should
not gain reward from their office and
therefore should not be taking
um
um
gifts bribes or or obtained in a
financial sense an advantage by Dent of
their their office
in the similar vein secret commissions
act
um
is the principle that a person holding a
position of trust should not make a
profit through their office
um and again it's an offense of someone
corruptly corruptly accepts or obtains
or solicits a gift or other
consideration just for doing their job
as an elected member or a deed an
officer and the council incidentally
does have a gifts policy which is quite
highly regulates the what can be
accepted as a gift and what must be
refused
and finally you worship the financial
Market conducts act it doesn't really
have any application to this Council
because we don't offer any public stock
offerings
happy to answer any questions and I hope
I haven't taken too much time
if you could hold that uh motion
councilor McKenzie
um thank you for that uh thank you for
that uh the chief executive so we have
um any comment or questions for the
chief executive on that um point
counselors trying to
um what is the limit for the gifts Act
is there a bottom cut off or is there
any sort of value
three years I think it might be a
hundred dollars but I just might need to
defer to the general manager corporate
support
50 50 sorry yeah
thank you
councilor heisted
you thanks Mr Mayor just a question
through you too
um the CEO
um in relation to the interest register
I realize it's coming up later on the
agenda but some of us in an employment
situation find ourselves appointed as
directors
trustees
that don't necessarily necessarily
involve your own personal interest but
involve that of other people what level
of detail is on this this published
register and is that information
necessary to be disclosed
three worship I can't give you an
absolute categoric answer at this point
in time we are working with the
invercargill city council to establish a
a template that we can both use but
trusts uh
um
are captured in this particular
legislation and I'd need to get to have
a take some advice or have a deeper
think about
trusts where I didn't have say an
elected member's employment
I would probably get down to how much
influence the role of trustee you have
and if it's
just for fulfilling a very you know
discreet set of Duties as opposed to a
wide ranging
and um quite a quite a powerful role as
a law encompassing trustee that might be
different but I needed to check on that
but we'll be working with elected
members over the next couple of months
on that basis
just the supplementary there so a
directorship would be taken as a direct
influence
yes thank you
Council Stringer
uh through your honor to the CE
um could you please also look into
um
holding companies are they required to
be supplied as well
thank you
any further discussion on this matter
uh brilliant
so the recommendation is that the
that information be received
do I have a mover
cancer Guardian seconder councilor Dixon
all those in favor please say aye
against
the motion is carried
I believe that brings us to the end of
the inaugural council meeting
um and I hereby declare it closed
um we will now take a one minute interim
so we have a break between the two
meetings and it and shake up your legs a
little bit and then we will get into
um the first uh council meeting thank
you
foreign
fantastic so we will draw attention back
to the council
and I will hereby open the
first council meeting how exciting
so once again care of the apologies from
from the previous meeting which are none
Declaration of conflict of interest as
the first one in here
so I will be declaring a conflict of
interest for
section number nine the meal expense
claim is at direct directly affects my
financial expenses do we have any other
conflicts around the table
sorry Declarations of conflicts around
the table
saw hi Sid just a question on item eight
uh Mr Mayor the report from the chief
executive
points to your potential conflict of
interest in that item do you intend to
stand down from the discussion on 11.
uh no I don't declare to stand down as a
conflict for the executive assistant to
the to myself
um is the mayor
um as that uh is a nice it's an
appointment by the chief executive
um essentially so who that staff member
is I don't get set aside
were there any other conflicts declared
I might also um declare conflict of
interest for the horizon
just so clarification was at item number
nine
affirmative okay
fantastic uh moving on to
uh confirmation of minutes
um as we can see in here from uh the
extraordinary meeting on the Thursday
6th of October 2022.
um they have been signed off by the
previous mayor and the chief executive
to confirm their correctness
uh the recommendation I'd imagine was
that they should be approved
foreign
yes yeah yeah so the the first one there
is just noting um that they they have
been signed as correct uh the second one
um we will need a confirmation from as
it is uh new Council
um the Declarations that was the
swearing-in ceremony
um so if I could
move the recommendation counselor
mcphail there Richard McDowell and
seconded by councilor Phillips
uh all those in favor please say aye
and the motion has been carried
right more into the fun stuff so there
is an update to the spring clean uh in
progress of the gore Aquatic Center and
conversations with the chief executive
this was a report put together just to
show not only councilors but the public
about
what's been happening at the Aquatic
Center and uh a bit of yeah progress
um
so we have a someone to move the motion
of receiving this report
counselor Reed and a secondary councilor
Dixon
and now the the floor is open for
discussion do we have any comments from
councils on us
counselorie thank you Mr Mia um I'd just
like to congratulate the staff for all
the hard work that they did and um
obviously everybody in the community is
looking forward to the opening of the
pool I also like to mention that the
communications over the delay and all
the extra work that went in were
brilliant many people I've heard comment
on that so well done
thank you councilor any further comments
counselor
um
there's appears to have been a lot of
extra work done do we have a costing of
or do we have a budget over around or
was it within budget
did you want to point a general manager
who might be able to speak to that
or yourself
um thanks I wish I might get uh the
general manager Community lifestyle
Services
I'm not familiar although maybe the
general manager corporate support in
terms of financials might be able to but
I'm not familiar or aware of any
notable cost overrun
thank you very shipping through your
worship there are additional maintenance
budget budgets that were used but it was
all within approved guidelines so
although a couple of additional things
items were undertaken the manager of the
Aquatic Center was checked in on a
regular basis to make sure the funding
was available so it's all within budget
can I just streaming wish it reinforce
our corporate service general managers
comments and assure councilor back to
now that our facilities manager actually
played a very strong hand in managing
the financial
budgets as the as the
maintenance program was undertaken and I
just want to reinforce councilor Reeds
boy then put on record publicly the
extra effort that the staff did to
ensure that it remained within budget so
the the staff spent numerous hours
actually doing some not so nice work
with regards to the regrouting and that
that was required in the pool but they
did that along with some of the
contractors of our community who also
volunteered to ensure that the um the
maintenance program remained within
budget and went that extra mile so I
think it's really important for us as a
council us as a community to recognize
the extra efforts that were undertaken
not just from our aquatic staff and
facility staff but also a number of our
local contractors and the ability for
them to work in with each other was
gratefully received from from certainly
our staff and and us as a council and I
just would want to make sure that that's
noted on public record
thank you for the input Rex and Lorne on
those points um good to hear that it
stucks the budget and um yes the the
staff put on some good work there
is there any further comments on this
report
right with that I
do we have in support
um please say hi
and against
and the motion is carried
foreign
next on the agenda is the naming of the
library and the James coming Wing
Community Center
so if counselors can flirt to that
including myself
uh in conversation with the chief
executive
um this is primarily a report that has
come to council
um as we we need a name for the library
and Community Center
um rather than just the the names that
are going out there in the community
um
I I have some yeah I have some comments
but I'll first move see if there is a
mover for this that the report shall be
received do I have a mover counselor
Reed and secondary councilor Stringer
open for discussion
so we had first up Robert Kinsey just
a point was it put up for public
consultation at all the naming of it uh
Chief is a consecutive if you could
answer that point
I Stanley corrected by
um Lorraine Winston Webb who's the
libraries manager and was involved with
the consultation along with Sony group
and GM
Communications and marketing but my
recollection is that the name was on the
plan of a building
um
that was when we went out to the public
to talk about the concert in the Library
community center
oh yes three worship
um the yeah when we put out the visuals
and stuff the name was um Gore library
and James coming Community Center
um I think this visual is also further
on that have gone out to the public
subsequently in discussions over um the
parking and Landscaping which had those
names on the building as well
it's just just a point I was wondering
wondering if the yeah no that's fine
thank you
thank you councilor
um because I said
you thanks Mr Mayor just a question for
you to um Mr Perry are we are we making
a decision tonight on the naming or is
this just a report that we're receiving
because a previous Council was did
Express The View that we should have a
have a public debate on the on the
naming I've realized there's been a bit
of time move on there's been names on
plans and names on the building that we
have approved but it would just seem to
me that the James Cummings Community
Center should be prominent as the as the
first name although it doesn't appear on
the building in that order and Library
um if it was up to me I'd be I'd be
flipping it over so first question is is
it up for
for discussion influence or is it too
late
so you worship it's never too late
councilor
uh vast
and yes the
um the report I guess
hints at this is what we think it should
be called and we'd like you to say yes
we agree
um but if there is a different view
let's hear it
um I thought I mean the the purpose
behind the report was I think something
my recollection was some councils last
term were getting
a little uncomfortable where different
people were calling the facility a
slightly different name and we thought
some bad habits might take root and
people were referring to it different
way so
um
again I probably need to defer to
Lorraine I think about how advanced the
end and Neil Mia their facilities office
about how advanced the the signage is
it's certainly been approved that way
but uh I mean because but that doesn't
stop a new name arising but it does seem
to be colloquially in the strong concern
in the community was that the name of
James Cummings should be preserved and
that was always attached to community
room usage as to think from a library
foreign
I'm Lorraine Western Webb the libraries
manager
um
it was really a question from Council
that they wanted a clarification it's my
memory of that meeting are we going to
call it this or are we going to call it
that so it was just clarifying what was
already being spoken and written
but there had been other ideas put
forward and if it turns out the council
would like that to be reviewed
it would be better to do it before we
put the names up on the outside of the
building
and according to the site managers some
of the
signage is already underway
at this stage this report has been a
slightly delayed coming to council
so there may be extra cost of there is
something different decided
thank you for that staff members uh
Council mcfarl
it's just uh three worship and in
response to some of that commentary
um it was around the the query uh as
there was a number of comments comments
that were going through media and
obviously through Council there was a
library hence why we wanted as part of
the community to recognize uh the iconic
and Heritage value of the fact that it
had been previously to James coming when
and recognized um for its entirety on
we're at um where it actually originated
from uh I am on of the oak of what uh
councilor Heist did has indicated that
the library still wasn't prominent in
front of the James [ __ ] uh Community
Center so maybe that could be a matter
that's referred back to the community
but the amendment may need to be made in
regard to a costing issue if we've
already started down a track then maybe
we can't stop the process
foreign
I'm wondering whether Council of heisted
would actually like to move it as a
motion
I'd actually like to leave that for the
rural counselors I think
this was from James coming and I think
it does strike Mr Council mcphail would
probably take that yeah I'm happy to
move the motion that we review the
effect of placing James coming
um
name
in the
start of the uh
well started the signage so the
amendment would be that the James
[ __ ] community center and library
I would second that
okay course the motion was moved by
councilor Richmond fail and seconded by
councilor hoval
um we yeah let's have some discussion on
this new Amendment so
um
I I just wanted to ask the question of
uh Sonia of regarding that consultation
with uh the community what how was that
received um so obviously it was it was
given out um do you have a general
understanding of what the community felt
through the worship our consultation
with regards to
so you said before that the the images
and things have been sent out to the
public did you get a understanding of
kind of how that was was received my
apologies um no we didn't get any any
feedback at all so one could assume it's
um positive just a point of
clarification
um the names James [ __ ] Community
Center and Gore Library the separate
entrances to each of those the names
will actually be split there's not going
to be one name running across it I'm not
sure if that helps clarify the order of
what the names will appear and
thank you thank you for that Sonia um
it's true to give you a comment
yes I want to worship there's a meeting
we're slightly cross purposes because
the motion put forward by councilor
heisted and councilor mcphail uh
suggests that the facility should be
referred to as the James [ __ ]
community center and library
and we have the two discrete entrances
on the building so with the motion be
satisfied if we all knew it as the James
[ __ ] community center and library
when we refer to that complex as opposed
to having to put that very long name on
two different entrances which could
cause a lot of confusion for the public
so in other words
could the motion be enacted without
actually changing signage
cool so there was a there was a yes uh
do we have any further comment I'll let
you do write a reply um
it may be easier for the motion to be
withdrawn then given that explanation
um but uh just through your worship and
regard withdrawing the motion uh the
fact is that we still would want the
reference as James [ __ ] community
center and library in regard to print or
um publication so the motion will not be
withdrawn although we accept that the
two separate entities are on recipients
of the building so
only factors you're driving are if
you're driving more south depends on
which side of the sign you're going to
read first
Council addiction did you have a comment
there
I'm just wondering if we could have a
complete new sign with some reference on
on it to um to the building itself and
how how the name James [ __ ] was
um
actually
put on that building in the first place
are you suggesting like a plaque like a
plot similar to a plaque but just
something to explain
um Mr James coming in the money that he
donated to the community and um that it
went to the James Cameron wing I would I
would imagine and to choose it because
um if yeah would I'm assuming there's
going to be a plaque for the whoever
ends up opening the building so that
could be included on that plaque is it
correct uh through your worship there
was a plaque in the old Center and I see
the facilities officer is running to my
rescue with some detail that he can
share with the meeting
uh yes and the original James [ __ ]
Hall there was a large
um photo uh there was actually two photo
one photo framed of James [ __ ]
himself and then there was another large
plaque that gave the information of the
James [ __ ] himself and also his image
we've still got both those saved on site
here and I have been talking to Jim
Getty's a while ago in regards to how we
can basically portray that inside the
James Cameron Community Center so that
the history still continues
foreign
alternative
um could there be some signage in the at
the library and maybe within the library
just to recognize James coming
because we've got very much got the
James coming Community Center down there
the library up here the library is going
to have huge amount of foot traffic so
perhaps to recognize James coming the
staff could consider the options around
some either internal or external signage
of of certain prominence just to reflect
the wish of councilman fell
foreign
Phillips thank you worship
I'm on the same lines as councilor
heisted in this moment and I'd like to
make a recommendation that knowing how
much signage costs and if it's uh quite
well down the track I don't think we
should be removing ourselves from
removing the names from the building and
almond and agree and said it should be
cooled the James coming in library
so perhaps we can have a sign outside in
front of the car park which indicates
that the both this building belongs to
the James coming Wing Community Center
also Jerry the James [ __ ] community
center and library at the front so
everybody entering the frontage of the
library and the frontage of the James
coming wing or Community Center can see
that and you're not altering anything in
the building
more experience and it can be in
partially with the new landscaping and
car parking in the front
that sounds like a yeah perfectly fine
recommendation do we
have any further discussion I'll have to
refer uh to Susan on what those
recommendations actually panned out
there before we move that motion of an
amendment
um
do we have any further comment or any
any contrary
um arguments as to naming it the James
[ __ ]
um James coming when community center
and library
nothing no no nothing I'll I'll second
Council mcphail's recommendation that we
call it the James coming when Community
Center in library from now on and the
silence be thought about in the front
and it's a part of the new upgrade of
car park and
um
whatever is going to be at the front
plants Etc
coso I believe that
um
that councilor Bridgeman fell brought
the amendment to the table and that cuts
the hoval seconded it originally
um and then that's added to the
recommendation that we think about some
tributary items inside the buildings in
the location of it uh is everyone happy
to move this motion
no objections uh everyone a favor please
say aye
and those against
the motion has been carried
all right it's on to the big stuff
um not that that was you know not big at
all
um
the matoto river crossing in Longford
shared Bridge next steps
so so just for clarification
um on this recommendation
um as as some people in the gallery and
potentially even councilors haven't
looked at the recommendation
um there are there are two options that
have been recommended regarding guessing
that water from one side of the river to
the other
uh those options are to continue to
explore opportunities for a dual purpose
Bridge
and the second is to solely focus on the
required pipeline across the matoto
river
so hopefully that's that's pretty clear
one
is a dedicated Dual Purpose bridge and
the other is figuring out how to get
that pipeline across the matoda river
whether that
um is directly across the river
um at Maitland Street installing a pipe
across the existing State Highway 1
Bridge or directly drilling the pipe
below the matoda river
um I believe the council wants some
direction in terms of what what is best
to explore
um so I will open that if I can get
someone to move the motion that this
report be received
um and that we provide some direction
regarding the prophetic steps of the
matoto river crossing and Longford
Bridge Project
received because the motion could be the
directive articulate about what you want
done okay okay uh sorry sketch that
um that's the recommendation here do I
have someone to move the motion that
just the report be received so councilor
Phillips and seconded by councilor Dixon
now do we now it's time for discussion
do we have anyone wanting to make some
points here councilor Garden
just just a question through your honor
to the Met paylist as is there room on
the existing state highway bridge for
the two pipes
and that was the argument from the start
yeah
whether there's room on the existing
bridge for two pipes or whether we need
to put a new bridge up
through your worship it's something that
we'd need to look into further
um it's not yeah
um and the existing service ducts is
unlikely to be sufficient space but
potentially it could be attached
somewhere else on the bridge
it's something that we certainly would
if if we're to go down that option we'd
need to look into it further and it
could become cost prohibitive but I
guess it's an option that's on the table
at the moment
thinks that councilor counselor Hotel
I'm reluctant to walk away from the
option of cycling and walking across the
river at the stage
I think that's something we should
continue to have on the table
but I'm curious as to the criteria that
three Waters Department would be looking
at using in terms of assessing the
options that are before us no doubt that
would include the financial cost of the
different options that have been
identified but I also believe that in
having a report looking at the options
we also need a high level assessment of
the different options in a table that's
looking at things like the cultural
impact and one of the options may have a
low cultural impact or it may have a
high cultural impact
the timing I'd like to know what how
critical is the timing to actually look
at this have we got time to go through
consenting process if we need to what's
the complexity with the different
options of the of the consenting
processes one would think that if it's
added to the state highway bridge
there'd be no consents but all the
others would require a consent and what
sort of cost would might be involved
something that Consultants would be able
to do and the technical complexities how
complex are each of the options before
us so I think as a council we need to
have an overview report that actually
compares the different options so that
we can focus and give some direction as
to which we believe should be followed
through but at this stage I believe that
the options should still include
The Pedestrian and cycling Bridge across
Financial Risk is also another matter
that should be looked at in that report
if we're not going to get any funding
from nzta what does that then expose the
council to so I guess I'm highlighting
the the need not only to focus on the
economics but also the environmental
impacts the visual impacts and
everything else
foreign
just to clarify your
um recommendation there was to include
not to single them out into option one
and option two but to get a table for
both all of the options available so um
and and four options have been
identified in the report it may well be
that there are other options that people
can identify around the table and the
staff can identify themselves and I
wouldn't want to rule out consideration
of any option on what is potentially
quite a controversial issue at this
stage
oh just before I let other Council to
speak could I just get clarification
from the chief executive on the timing
of the the matter at hand um in terms of
the urgency
all right through your worship
um yeah I just um
like to respond to that I guess and
provide out my thoughts and
um I guess as councilor hervell has
alluded to
um there's quite a bit of complexity
there particularly associated with the
Dual Purpose bridge and certainly if we
go down the the that path we will need
to do quite a robust options assessment
and present all the options and and
consider them all
um I guess the purpose behind this
report is is to go through that options
assessment
um
will take quite a bit of work and
there'll be a reasonable kind of
um amount of cost associated with that
if we're to solely focus on the pipeline
across the river then that removes a lot
of that complexity
um
so I guess we're wanting to get some
direction from the council before we go
down that path of looking at the Dual
Purpose option and spending a reasonable
amount of money we don't have a good
understanding what that amount would be
at this stage and that's something that
would need to look into further
but wanting to just make sure that we're
on the right path before we we go down
too far
I guess to the the question around
timing
um certainly
um the Dual Purpose Bridge or a bridge
will take longer and need to go through
that resource consenting process
um if we were to go down at uh um
the option of directionally drilling
Under the Bridge Under the river or
attaching a pipe to the state highway
bridge then the chances are we wouldn't
need a resource consent and that would
significantly reduce our timing and I
guess I'll just mentioned there that um
the K driver behind this project is
um to make sure that
um all of Gore has drinking water that's
compliant with the New Zealand drinking
water standards and until we get that
pipeline across the bridge
um
the the western side of sections of the
western side of Gore won't have water
that's compliant with drinking water
standards
do you wish me if I can just clarify yes
sorry could I just hold you there um
Keith uh yeah the I think the and kids
might be able to say correct me if I'm
wrong here but around the urgency of how
long do we have to make this decision
these requirements about the water
quality coming down on us quite hard I
don't know if
um who's who's the right person to
answer that but I've obviously realized
that it's urgent regardless but what
kind of is that the urgency
through your worship
um is at this stage there's no specific
date set as to when we need to have
um
need to reach compliance with the
drinking water standards however I
suspect with the establishment of tomato
Arrow y
um they will be looking at imposing
specific dates
um but at this stage there's no specific
dates but we obviously want to do it as
soon as possible
thank you thank you for that did that
clarify for you and I'll
sorry I'll let other councils speak and
then we'll Circle back if you if you
still have it uh counselor appointment
thank you worship um the one key thing
about this whole party we've got to get
the community behind us that was a
massive issue um that I've been talking
to people about for ages got to get them
to let people know what's going on and
and show the options and put it out
there because there's been considerable
amount of money spent on this already
obviously and
um I don't want to get shot in the
street for uh for something like this so
I think we need to talk to the community
and make sure they're well well informed
thanks for that counselor Council hosted
hey thanks Mr Mayor um look as a former
counselor
I was informed that the state highway
bridge was ruled out directional
drilling was ruled out so
um I I and we'd been through this over a
long number of years so we're at now I
think before anything happens we need a
very high level report on a with a rough
order of costs and some basic visuals
and we need to get out and consult with
the community and there's two options a
bridge with a pipe or a bridge with um
dual dual axes and we need to get on
with that and get out the community
because Paul was quite right the
community need to have their say that's
where the last process failed in terms
of consultation
and I see there's only two options and
unless the world's changed since uh
since we last looked at this
and I I think that's yeah in line with
um councilor hovel's point there as well
um and also councilor mcphails uh next
up uh councilor Dixon
thank you worship
um look I'm I'm inclined to agree with
that I think we should have Community
consultation
um particularly because of the path that
we have been down and the community are
quite um they would like to be involved
with this there is one other option and
I'm and I think it may need environment
Southlands approval to do this but it
has been suggested that you could put a
pipe into the riverbed rather than
trying to drill underneath the riverbed
do you have any comments on that please
Matt
through your worship
um I'm aware that that's been suggested
um quite a bit
um I believe
um that getting the required consent for
that could be extremely difficult
um and
um you know in this day and age it's
probably highly unlikely that would get
the required approvals but we can
certainly
investigate it I'm sure the likes of
hakunu and things like that would be
um very interested in any sort of
application around that
can I also ask too that that we involve
the ewe very early on in this
consultation process as well
yeah Julie noted
um
Matt on that one has uh his environments
often been consultant on this this
progress have there been discussions
with them about kind of the goings on
there
that we worship yes there's certainly
been a number of discussions
um
regarding this project with environment
Southland
obviously there was an initial cons a
consent required through environment
Southland for the initial proposal and
then we've had some preceding
discussions since the environment Court
decision around potential auctions and
would continue to talk to environment
South and around that
I think if they met Council Reed and
then councilman
thank you Mr Leah um I'm actually in a
grants with councilor heisted on this
one we're beating around the bush we're
Reinventing the wheel again we've got
two options and let's just investigate
those two at this stage and engage with
the community I think that's they're the
three priorities in my book
thank you councilor councilor McDonald
I've written on my piece of paper here
and I'm in total agreement with
councilor heinstead Maitland Street two
estimates Pike Bridge only bridge for
walking and cycling and consult with the
community you need something to actually
say to them these are the options and
I'm totally against going down to the
other Bridge one because the distance
apart you've got the longer you make
your pipes the more trouble you can have
secondly secondly you touch the pipes
you're going to be attached under the
bridge presumably
and there's a hellish and flood wrist
when it comes through there there'll be
massive trees come down that River I
know working for the paperwork 20 years
they ended up outside my office there so
how are you going to protect the pipes
under the bridge uh if the massive flood
comes down so that's my concerns on that
bridge so I'm fully in support of
councilor heisted's Direction there
thank you
uh councilor Phillips
thank you where is it well I've sat and
listened to everybody and
I'm absolutely getting just
a little bit annoyed about how long this
is taking we initially wanted a pipe
bridge to take pipes across the the
matara river
then came up the idea about having a
shared Bridge
so here in lies why are we still four
years down the track and nothing's
happened and cost us a lot of money
the staff are asking us for Direction
make a decision today so they can get on
with it so we can get the water over
the river
we went down the track about going under
the river unknown cost
ask your friends at MVM
a bridge was a known cost
a cost comes to council we know what the
cost is we can relay that to the right
path
the bridge can be put in for a 50 to 100
years we can build the bridge so if
e-score expands we can put pump stations
across there giving us an alternative
Pump Station from escort currently we
only have one
and those are the kinds of things that
we've got to think about
the best option is
let's get the staff on the track to get
it done
and Council Heist is right let's get it
done get a report from and I like to
move that we have
one Bridge
carrying rip pipes across from Maitland
Street
um coming to and from and build the
bridge so it's in an existence can have
existing pipes
for the future
so whether that be storm water sewer or
whatever it might be
to come bring them back to our oxidation
ponds and later on to our BMR plant
and those are the kind of things that
we've got to think about because
currently if we wanted to separate
e-score from stormwater we were going to
take it
do we have to go down the down the line
again once again saying do we have to go
under the river again no
so let's build it once let's build it
for the future and it may cost a little
bit more but at least we can say that
we've done it once and done it right
thank you
sorry I was just thinking there
um
there's a there's a number around that
say I mean I guess I guess we'll get a
second if there's a second of her for
news about a second of there
um so we got so the move of the motion
did we want to clarify what the motion
was yeah yeah yeah yeah
and and I think I think there should be
discussion there's a number of
recommendations that have been passed
around and my recommendation was that I
agreed with what council highstead had
said that we need it
need to have a report
from the staff with their recommendation
and my recommendation is that we go with
one single Bridge across the Matera
River at Maitland Street
yes and so with dual option so we're
potential for walking and cycling
facility as well
two options
I'll give you that one
thank you
I'm just going to get the comment stuff
on this
um just I don't know we've kind of
jumped ahead of the recommendation
that's in the report so
um we'll move it to start for this one
just just uh one one point of
clarification really is that for Council
to be um really across is that
regardless of what type of bridge we
build on that at that location
um doesn't mean it can be that it's
going to be guaranteed to be approved
whether it's a pike Bridge or a job
purpose bridge that can still be
challenged in terms of its environmental
effects
um and so you need to weigh that up
versus when this is sort of what the I
guess the report was trying to get at is
versus the directional drilling which
has some unknown costs but has the
benefit of not having to go through that
likely not even to go through that
consent process so just in terms of that
that final Direction I think that's
really important because we don't want
to come back
um you know three four months down the
track after going through consultation
and then you weren't really clear that
can still be approved or declined
through that consenting process
so did you want to respond to that or
I think he or is it I I understand what
the pros and cons are
but
the thing about it is we've got to start
we've got to get it going and I
understand if we do it right this time
we should have some success
so what let's make sure that we do it
right
consultation consultation consultation
cancer High Val
I followed very closely
the previous consent that went through
and on the basis of that I would not
like to see us put all of our eggs in
one basket as to a potential site for
putting the structure across the river
because there are other
examples that are available in terms of
a crossing point be it at Nelson Street
or elsewhere
and until we have a high level report
that actually compares the different
options it would be unwise for us to say
that is the one we want to go out and
consult on I want to know rough order a
cost and if you look at the cost of the
bridge
um that went through the consenting
process and look at a high order
assessment of other options even even if
it's in qualified quantif qualifiable
terms high medium low or the risk Etc
what's the information that we don't
have what are we exposing ourselves to
in Risk so that's that's why I'm adamant
that we still need to be looking at
maybe four or five options coming back
to council then at that stage picking
two to compare and go out to public
consultation before proceeding further I
take the comments from Mr Bayless in
terms of how urgent it is how soon we
have to get on to this is we have time
and we should be doing it in a
structured sort of way
so just just to get some order back into
into the conversation
um so councilor Phillips has moved the
motion that we focus solely on option
one and get some determinations around
what that would actually look like so
that we have Direction
um do we have a secondary for that
motion
no no second for
all right
so I would if the location wasn't
specific if it was we we have the
flexibility in a dual purpose Crossing
or a just a pipe Crossing just based on
um consenting
um
bakeries
so my understanding of the motion was
was to take the recommendation of
looking into looking into option one and
getting some further clarification
information on that is that correct
councilor Phillips
great but the recommendation is a um
Maitland Street recommendation at the
top
and
after after all after going through the
whole process earlier on and right from
the start of this this proceeding
I believe that we're a better chance if
we specifically say that's where we're
going to be
stop memory around the different options
and think about what's the best thing
for the future what's the best thing for
now if it's a shared bridge at Maitland
Street okay then we'll come up with the
thing benefits if it's not the right
place
everybody in around this table once we
get the report we'll have that decision
to be made
and if if it is the right place then
let's get ahead and get it done
so once again sorry counselor I'm just
gonna just to clarify on that that
Amendment to the Motions or you're
pushing for the the
motion that option one will be explored
and all options regarding that bridge
whether it's location costs
um Community impact will be provided to
council so that creep so you're moving
moving that motion and do we have it do
we have a second in councilor heisted or
are you still thinking on that one
I'm sorry uh Mr mirror refers option one
is the Dual Purpose bridge and we've
discussed that it could be either single
you know pipe only or dual purpose
um in that one location so we need the
community to tell us in my view do they
want pipe only what's your purpose and
what it what the cost ramifications at a
higher level are in some imagery so we
can consult
that's what I had one
okay so I think there are two two
separate motions here then
um regarding this it seems like
incorrect me if I'm wrong um councilor
heisted and councilor hoveau's motion
seem very similar in terms of providing
a more generalized overview of the
options at hand and then having that
open to the community as well so they
can see those options and then when
those options are provided then we might
be able to make it a better decision on
that is that correct or would we like to
form I just would like to get a emotion
on the table and it's sickened so we can
have a discussion around whatever that
motion is
could be refer to the chief executive to
try and guide us to
come up with something that the staff
can work with I think I think everyone
on the table has got a similar intent we
want councilor Phillips that's right we
want to get on with it but we don't want
to tie the staff's handle these
council's hands to something that we
that uh isn't successful
yeah if you could kind of that was
through you worship I think what the
meeting wants is
a analysis of a dual purpose bridge that
can potentially carry just
uh water and wastewater pipes or walking
cycling on a select few locations
from the extremes of Maintenance Street
and two or three other locales heading
towards the existing Main Street Bridge
with high level costings and imagery
associated with it in order that you can
either say these three or four options
we can share the community or get down
to perhaps a couple or even one and
um and proceed on that basis knowing of
course that there is still the direct
drilling under River as a point of Last
Resort should those costings prove to be
very challenging because I'm acutely
aware that since we last
assessed the cost of the former design
the construction Market has moved
appreciably and the pockets of
wakakatahi or nzta have shortened
appreciably so that those things will
all go onto the mix
is that a fair summation of what you'd
like to see come before the council
yeah I think the the agency here is
Paramount one to do with costings and
two but for the impending
um regulation that we're going to have
to stick to uh do we have any further
comment I'm just trying to formulate
what this what this motion actually
looks like Council Dixon
thank you worship just to
um just to be able to make a decision I
believe if we go to Maitland Street
there will be no Waka kahati funding
um at all so that means that it'll be up
to council to pay the full cost which
then leads me back to going out to the
community we need to know if they're
prepared to to front that cost and and
correct me if I'm wrong chief executive
I'd imagine that wakurotahi probably
isn't going to get involved in really
any any project given their current
funding status
uh well we do know that the budget for
walking and cycling projects and this is
which the the bridge would be funded out
of has been reduced
I've already been told a few months back
that their funding situation is
challenging
um and
ironically what a guitar he still have a
marked preference for the site that was
the subject of the big decline decision
from the environment Court but those
things are better off coming from the
staff with your direction and and
perhaps with updated estimates it may
become quite Crystal Clear what the real
feasible options are and what the also
ends so hence my suggestion of maybe the
staff coming up with you know three or
four
practical options for a dual purpose
bridge at certain locations including
Maitland Street and then they can
perform the basis of a more informed
discussion with a viewer going out to
the people with your more refined choice
of locations
councilor Garden
you saw I was involved in the perimeter
Bridge it took us seven years from go to
work and it's actually got blown out
before it got and we increased our
subsidy but just a real lesson from the
Perma Bridge was when we actually put
the tenders out for the design that it
cost us three to four hundred thousand
we had alternative painters that were
put in by the industry and we actually
accepted one of them at two million
dollars less than the estimates
so we could have saved ourselves an
awful lot of money about 900 000 if we
just put it as a Tanger out for design
and build a bridge
and it actually would have sped the
whole operation up and you got you've
got an Innovative you could get an
Innovative designer bridge builder they
have set plans and they have their own
engineers and of course would have to
get a peer reviewed that would speed the
whole process
you'd have to decide on a site or it let
them decide
thank you councilor councilman fell
I think you worship I think one of the
key things is the design was an issue I
around the community location was one
thing that the design was a key factor
to and I think coming up with some
options of designs is and going to the
community and saying what do you think
of what do you like look at that because
that would be a great thing to do if we
could
as part of the whole process
Council McDonald
well last comment uh the further you go
down the river the more pipe you've got
to put in the more costs there is so the
further you keep up to Maitland Street
there's no very little piping you
straight across so the savings to be
made
so that the Bridget Maitland Street as
far as piping would go be the far the
cheapest option
Council and actor now and then Council
Mackenzie
so sorry counselor got on I was looking
right at you
um just just two points on that one is
um
stewardess
uh the shortest route is the best route
but if you actually visit the site the
banks are not as stable at Maitland
Street as you may for a bridge builder
you may want to go down a weaver to good
rock and you need to leave that a little
bit flexible because it'll be a
trade-off between foundations and
lengths and against bright blinks so you
need to have some flexibility in the
system
the councilor McKinsey
you worship I just clarifying with Matt
there is no resource consent necessary
to go under the river
is that what you see before sorry I just
wanted to clarify that point through
your worship uh that's my understanding
yeah we'd have to double check that but
um my understanding is that when
pipelines were installed for the Matera
Valley milk development there weren't
resource consents required because the
worship I can correct that the council's
district plan has a provision in it
saying that if Earthworks taken I think
it's more than three months then you
need a resource consent to disturb
ground including ground under the river
and in the case of matara very milk they
had two extensions to their resource
consent from the gore District Council
they did not need a consent from
environment Southland
so thank you
thank you for that Matt
right we've got a we got a motion
Brewing here I think the general
consensus around the table is to go with
a bridge
um and to focus our research efforts on
on a bridge so that we can at least give
direction to the staff about areas to
explore
am I getting that General consensus
around the place
did anyone want to move emotion around
something broader around the the bridge
than than what the motion that councilor
Phillips had brought up or
have we got a bit more support for that
motion now anyone want to oh Matt did
you want to comment
thank you worship um yeah I just came to
I just ask a question
um
and
um I guess as I alluded to earlier
there's going to be a reasonable amount
of
um
money required to investigate options
and things like that
um to I think come to bring the
information that you need and get the
high level costs and things like that
um
do you want us to go out and consult
with the community and ask them whether
they want us to continue down the path
of a dual purpose Bridge or just focus
on the
pipeline first before we do that
investigation work or do you want us to
do the investigation work
spend some money and then consult with
the community
my
I'll let I'll let counselor have else
speaker if he feels like oh cancel read
sorry thank you I think we need to give
the community the options um as to what
they want and then and they need to be
able to see what they want
um or the options that they're going to
choose from there's no point in US
telling them that they're going to have
a bridge that looks like a b c d because
we've been down that road or Bridge
pardon pun but yeah no I I'd really like
to see us give them some options Matt
please
counselor
several of us have talked about a high
level assessment I don't see a need to
get into con incurring considerable cost
by the council to actually look at what
the cost of the different options are
we've we've had costing done for a
bridge in a certain location
what we need to know is that at that
rough order a cost at the other sites
that we're looking at uh are we looking
at more complex issues or or similar
um so at the high level I'm not
expecting to see a detailed breakdown of
design or the rest of it
um because one of the issues that's
raised is that the design is probably
one of the critical issues that the
public would want to comment on
so in terms of
um in some respects it would be better
not to see any numbers in the report
that comes back to council other than
the complexity that you're going to have
at this site is is more than at site A
or B
I would rather see it in that format as
the initial Shakedown and prior to going
out to consultation with the council we
reduce the number of options and provide
some more information
but we've got to keep the design
flexible in part the the opposition to
the previous one was the design as well
as the visual impact of the location
did you want to put a motion to that
effect if there's no other comment
all right I'd move that the staff be
directed to report back to the council
in terms of options that may be
available for a bridge that provides for
the three Alternatives that we've been
talking about
um at various locations in the river so
that we can provide further direction
for more detailed assessment and that
that be a high level
assessment looking at the different
effects
do I have a second of that motion
uh Council Reed
is there any further discussion to that
Amendment
no
wow do we Okay cool uh let's put that to
a vote then
um
all those in favor please say aye
and then gint
the motion is carried
thank you for that counselor
so the next on the agenda is the school
district council recycling update
rethinking waste
foreign
there are quite a few recommendations
um in there but first off do we have a
motion that that report be received
uh councilor Rich mcphail the seconder
councilor Phillips
open to discussion
when people are ready
uh councilor Dixon
thank you worship
um
I note in this report that we're talking
about glass and we're still talking
about crushing glass
I believe there's a market for clear
glass if you can separate colored glass
from clear glass this is quite a good
market for that so I'm wondering if we
could perhaps have a
a report on how easily it would be to
separate the glass so we can sell off
the clear glass from the colored glass
which would then um
there wouldn't be such huge amounts of
crushed glass at our transfer station
and I also note that food is our largest
waste
and so and it releases methane and I see
the government is taking the stance to
um
to change this and and to
that we have to collect food waste but I
think it should come with funding from
central government as well because
there's a quite a huge cost for us to
recycle and that costs falling back on
our rate payers so I believe that we
should be pushing central government for
some funding if they want food taken out
of our waste stream
thank you that counselor or Tinder agar
I think this report uh indicates in it
that there was some work done by the
otago mural Forum around us in
particular issue
um I don't believe the report contains
and correct me if I'm wrong uh
how what what discussions actually had
there but I think furthering its
investigation in terms of what has been
decided once again not Reinventing the
wheel but we might be able to get some
comment on that
uh through your worship
um thanks that question uh glennis the
the recommendation from Nikki bold the
consultant really is around trying to um
utilize glass locally
um so it would be interested just sort
of whether what options you are locally
to recycle even the separated glass from
the discussions to date what we are
trying to do to complete the uh circular
economy
in terms of recycling glass is to crush
it through a process with
um that we're investigating through
McGregor's concrete and looking at how
that can then be utilized across
different
materials such as a bidding material
where it's whether it's distributed
through an ap20 or we're looking at
other options to crush it down and use
it as drainage bedding or in in drains
itself to around different low-risk
Council options so the the key thing
around the glass is trying to avoid
having to transport it because the
transport of glass is extremely costly
and it's
full form and I guess the other point is
just to ensure that we're
also that note that the separation of
glass comes with a cost too so having to
separate colored from uh clear glass
certainly um was a process that has a
cost Associated to it so we're trying to
balance it out but as the report
outlines there's some ongoing work
around the best use for glass but we're
certainly trying to do that and trying
to do it locally if we can within the
region
uh Council heisted
thanks Mr Mayor I just um
I just wonder if also other options
could be explored rather than just
resuming a full-scale curbside recycling
for example glass if you travel to
cities go to student areas there's
there's glass igloos you know for for
the students to deposit your glass you
know there could be options for those to
be scattered throughout the community so
through if the staff could also take
that into account I see also that we
have a member of the picky Lions
presence and that just this reminds me
that that we do have a community that's
actively involved in this space and it
would be great that they were engaged
with as as part of this process because
they are gauze recycling at this present
time and I think we should recognize
that and learn from their wisdom
Council Richmond Fair
yeah obviously um through your worship
and through to
um Jason uh in regard to the
minimization officer and the levies that
we've been getting charged I've asked
this previous times whether we actually
look at
um with that role that's being adopted
into the plan whether we can actually
get some funding through central
government on in regard to those levees
because I think there is funding paths
in there
uh through you worship there's certainly
um there are a number of
um funding Avenues and that's what
touches on the point to other point that
that glennis raised around Organics we
we uh certainly will be looking at every
option around that and that is really
the the outcome that we're seeking today
is to be able to go away investigate
those and bring a full Suite of options
back to council that can maybe offset
costs use existing Levy funding or look
at ways to minimize the cost of the
ratepayer through a number of different
options so certainly leaving everything
on the table at this point Thank you and
just for the comment there you worship
uh just in regard to that willingness to
resume having been part of the workshops
and uh not actually being a resident of
town I am aware of the huge number of
people within the community that want
some sort of recycling curbside
recycling to happen and it's a continual
at the workshops was a continual bug
beer that came up so that's probably why
I have full support to that resuming of
the service or any negotiations that we
can impart that may improve us uh also
add into that in regards to the levy
situation that we should be actively
encouraging our recyclers and I think my
fellow councilor Heist is referred to
the cardboard recycling done by pakiki
that we should be actively supporting
them I know we do grants but at the
current world situation the cost of
cardboard being recycled is very very
low on their return and also the fact
that um that if we put that cardboard
that they recycle over our transfer face
we pay by the Tongue and I think it's
vicinity of about 650 tonne they put
through a year and we pay the living if
that was to go over to the transfer site
we'd be paying for that
thank you councilor uh councilor
I fully support the staff doing a
further report to us in terms of costing
options right through to the full
recycling in the urban area over the
last six months and over the election
period there were several key issues
that were came out constantly and
recycling was near the top of that list
in addition the youth Council has been
promoting and and the youth
more widely
um
the youth Council has been promoting
adoption of recycling being looked at
again and and for those reasons I fully
support what has included in the
recommendations
councilor Reed the comment thank you I
do
um one thing I would like to note with
the park hikis that they also recycle
aluminum which I think at the moment is
actually quite lucrative but whether
members of the public know that perhaps
our Communications person who's not in
the room might be able to chase that up
again on behalf of parkiki
and the other thing is I think I'm quite
happy to move the recommendation
and definitely giving consideration to
the dedicated waste minimization officer
because I think that's the only way
going forward that somebody's dedicated
in that space
should be actually pushing these things
and driving it but I would also like to
thank Jason for the report it's a good
one and as I said I'm happy to
support that recommendation
before we moved that the further motions
on here is there any further comments
no there is a bit further comment from
me so
um Jason I just want some clarification
I've got a couple of points actually
um the first one being have we looked
into
um putting out an expression of interest
for actually Contracting out the entire
service so not handling it by Council
but making uh the rate payer charge so
charging the right person separately and
then we take that off their rate has
there been any consideration into an
option like that
foreign
the the old system that we did have is
is a contracted system
um so if if there was going to be a
reinstatement of the service or a
modification of that service uh it would
still be a contracted service there is
no in-house Service delivery when it
comes to refuse collection or disposal
sorry to clarify so that the
recommendation is there to get to to
work with ICC again which in talking to
me and Nobby Clark uh they're more than
happy for us to get back involved with I
was
um I was expressing expressing an
interest of um completely separate of
that so whether there is a contractor
who who would actually take on that role
so they get they get paid separately to
the council we don't we don't pay for it
rate pays pay for it person by person
basis and where the consideration has
been taken to that I know that kcdc and
and wimac have had that service and
there's a number of councils around the
country that have changed that model I
just wonder if there's any been any
consideration into that model
is so you worship I think um there's
certainly some pros and cons to
um having a fully
um contacted service such as that um
undertaken by companies such as waste
management and others around the country
um however
it may be able to be done at a slightly
cheaper price but the the con is really
what it takes out of your communities
um so we need to be aware of of the
economic
um uh implication of of a of a system
like that and again for Southland it's
obviously a little bit harder just given
our location uh to to centers so
certainly through uh through wastenet
and through our relationships with Bond
contracts and recycle South there's uh
opportunities there about those um I
guess that's part of the consideration
about trying to do things slightly
differently here in the South and get
the best outcome for our community
think of it Jason uh what I am quite
Keen to do is to break this down into to
three three separate motions
um this this recommendation um because
they're they're all quite different uh
so do I have so the first recommendation
is that the council note the willingness
of inversity
Council recycle South and bond contracts
LTD to support and reintroduce kurd
cyber recycling collection service for
Gore and matoda do I have a motion
um does anyone want to bring that motion
forward
a recommendation forward for that motion
uh councilor hovel and a seconder
uh councilor mcphail
do we have discussion on that in
particular motion about
um going and talking to invercargill
city council again and
understanding the ins and outs of of
working with with them and their
recycling
it's the Mover if I can speak to them
the emotion is saying is we are noting
the willingness I would suggest that we
don't really need to debate it it's
merely an observation and um I think you
can put the motion
so I was more one saying if there was
any interest to broaden that out into
conversation but we can keep it at a
willingness that's that's fine councilor
Dixon
okay
um thank you Mr Beer
um I'm just wondering about the cost
because I know that last time we debated
this and the cost was quite High to go
back through
um recycle South so is that changed is
it still the same cost and
um yes so that was that was something
that I think we need to know before we
approve or our women
and I'll let this the staff answer this
as well but I believe that the Motions
just for the willingness
um rather than the kind of Internet site
I think we will find out more of that um
in due course but if if staff still want
to speak to that um more than happy to
through your worship that's correct so
we we're not um what we're certainly not
saying that there aren't going to be um
costs involved with um carrying out the
service but what we want to do is make
sure that there is a willingness for us
to go and obtain those and provide a
suite of options to council and into the
community for consideration
Brilliance so any further discussion
around that
call all those in favor say please say
aye against motion is carried
into the next one that's there that
there is a willingness to resume a
curbside recycling collection service
that the scope and assist cost of any
such service be identified and then the
subject of community re-engagement with
a view to resume a full-scale curbside
recycling service from that first of
July 2023
do we have any one to move that motion
councilor Dixon and second to council
Richmond fail and I open it to the floor
to discussion on that one uh councilor
Phillips thank you Richard I just
started the question about
um the date first of July 2023 are the
staff quite comfortable with that time
frame
foreign
at this point that's the aim um and we
will report back to councilworth there
is a concern about meeting that time
frame but we're mindful of the fact that
there is community uh in Council
um appetite to get this back up and
running and so we're trying to push for
that date and
um we'll certainly keep you informed if
there's any movement on that throughout
the process
just to touch on that is there any
possibility of getting it done sooner
within reason of course
I just uh
probably not I think we wouldn't want to
make sure that we
consider all those costs appropriately
and then
um as part of our
recognized in in terms of their annual
plan for the following year so just
making sure that we align which is why
that time frame has sort of been
selected
thank you for that Jason uh Council
heister
I guess my concern with the second
recommendation that doesn't pause
um on the cost issue it goes straight to
assessing the cost and scope and taking
that to the community it doesn't allow
the council to put it through any
financial model annual plan or debate
around this table so I would be voting
against that in its current form unless
the move is willing to change it I
believe it's just as important to go
through an annual planning process as as
the waste minimization officer It's a
larger cost it's significant
we just I know there's there's a real
willingness to get on with it and get
this done but it has to go through a
process
being the annual plan that's the only
process with the media price we have
yes thanks for worship um the councilor
High School rate is a good point the
annual plan
uh is is not mandatory to consult if
you're not uh making a a decent
departure from your long-term plan this
would be a departure because if we've
placed the service on on life supporters
as I refer to it
but the fact that you're doing community
engagement and if you're getting a clear
feedback from the community
um it would all depend on whether
you will do opt to consult on your
annual plan or believe you've got enough
direction from the community to box on
and just adopt it in your plan and
introduce a service so I can see both
sides of the argument but the the
resolution is that you will go to the
community
and seek their views with costs attached
and I would suggest that depending what
those costs are the answer might be
reasonably compelling if it's a steep
increase in cost from what was the price
of
2020
the community may
not be so enthusiastic to embrace a full
blind curbside recycling system so
it's I think I personally think there's
sufficient checks and balancing system
because this is going to come back to
you the council with the costs and all
you're committing to do here is to go to
the community with sufficient
information to give you a clear
direction as to whether you should
reintroduce the service in full in part
or not at all
experience tells me to disagree with the
chief executive this is a staff are
given a mandate from this meeting under
this recommendation there is not a pause
on the financial implication it says
that we're going to resume recycling on
one July 23 after engaging with the
community so I would like
a slight Amendment just just to ensure
that it does come back to stable I we
have we have been here before and
respect the staff yes I'm sorry if I'm
sounding a little bit different but we
do just need to be tight so
um rather than move an amendment I just
wonder if there's a suggestion that the
Mover and secondary would would agree
with
and if you if you could run that
Amendment um anyway councilor heisted
thanks just so it's really really clear
because it's it's quite detail
orientated in there
foreign
so it would breed that if there's a
willingness to resume a curbside
recycling service the scope and assess
cost of any service be identified and
subject to approval by Council then be
the subject of community engagement
so I have that moved by uh councilor
hovel and seconded by
heisted did you want to second that one
or
yep cool so that that Amendment stands
and we'll have discussion on that
Amendment as well
um Council McDonnell
right
any further discussion
perfect uh all those in favor please say
aye those against
motions carried
uh so then then the motion sorry yep
yeah
so uh we'll move that that motion I'm
assuming the same mover
yes in the same second though yep and uh
all those in favor of the motion please
say aye
perfect and that's against fantastic
uh and the last one here is that the
council give consideration to employing
a dedicated waste minimalization officer
through the 2324 annual plan process do
I have a mover for that
councilor Reed seconded by councilor
heisted and open for discussion
councilor mcdonell is this going to be a
full-time fde or a part-time job what
what is the order of cost
can I direct that
uh just to just to clarify I think and
once again creepy information I think
the recommendation is that we'll take
consideration so it'll be discussed
further um in the annual plan process
but um did you have rough estimates that
you want to comment on or not not really
uh through you worship uh not at the
stage um there's certainly a uh a
movement across
um the country now with the changes in
legislation to have minimization offices
across Council to manage uh that and
certainly we will be able to look at
what other councils are doing in and see
costs uh some
um approximate costs to put in front of
council as part of their annual plan
process
yeah my only concern with this
recommendation
um is is a lot around the job
description and the the role and the
purpose of this waste finalization
officer um but I understand that after
consideration is given uh around the
annual plan process we will have a
deeper understanding before making a
final decision
um on that so
um if everyone is there any other
comments on that would waste
minimalization officer
uh counselor Stringer
thank you thank you worship
um what does this person income with any
pairs or responsibilities
um with their position of um Vice
minimization like do they have the
ability to
um act upon fly tapping
I think that's yet to be determined but
some maybe some general advice or based
on maybe what other councils are doing
that you may have seen
yes I thought you wish now the waste
minimization officer
um is more around education
communication promotion of best practice
issues around fly tipping is really the
regulatory arm of the council's response
uh which uh Mrs Francis Shepherd takes
care of so yeah this is more about
actually getting out there within the
community and promoting good practice
and encouraging people to minimize their
waste
uh so with that
um obviously counselor
um McDonald has just stepped out of the
room but um do we can we get a um
um I'd like to yeah see support for the
motion so um those into part of the
emotion please say aye
and the motion is carried
might just take a quick intro if that's
okay with everyone just while
um councilor McDonald has a toilet break
I'm guessing is that all right with
everyone
to see
yeah we'll resume and say two minutes
thank you
if we could slowly bring attention back
to the council now that all councilors
have relieved themselves
oh well not all of them
brilliant well I've quiet in the
chambers
so there's going to be a quick uh change
of order here with these next points uh
so I'm going to defer 0.8 which is
executive assistant says worship the
mayor and address 0.9 first
um so 0.9 is mural expense claimed for
the trip to Wellington and attend the
New Year's meeting I'd like to inform
counselors
oh we've got a Wanderer
foreign
public that they're all costs related to
my personal assistant I've accepted the
cost
um as she was my personal assistant and
I don't think that it should be
um taken on by by the council
um following the recommendation by uh
staff and also conversations with with
counselors
um I will follow current procedures to
those claims claims for myself
um and therefore this this part of the
agenda will be withdrawn and there will
be no further discussion on this this
matter
going back to point number eight uh
which is the executive assistant for his
worship Vermeer
so I think some explanation
um by me as needed here is to why this
is on the agenda
um
as as many people will know I've had my
own own personal assistant
um helping me out uh in the interim
um I was you know heavily affected by by
media and things
um being thrown at me
um and I I didn't think that was fair on
the The Joint
um assistant of both myself and the
chief executive um it also pulls that
resource away from the chief's executive
and I just wanted to get a general
feeling for what council's thought was
around this issue hence why it has been
brought forward
um it is a matter of support for myself
and and therefore so that I can help
help counselors out on their issue
um the the this whole the whole
recommendation is a entirely a matter of
political discretion for the council so
it's a discussion that we need to have
around the recommendation my
initial thought around
um
hours salary job description that sort
of thing I think will need to be be you
know sought out by the chief executive
further to whether this whether this
position is open or not
um I won't hold the floor for much
longer I know that there are some people
who want to want to speak on this um
this issue so so I have a mover for uh
the
well I guess we don't need to move for
the motion do we we'll have to come up
with one but I I'll open the open the
floor to discussion um are there people
in favor of the movement first
I think
uh you worship I think procedurally we
should have a discussion and from that
emotion be developed either positive or
negative
yeah yeah absolutely so can we we'll
have that we'll have that um open
discussion did you want to lead the
proceedings or anyone else
um Council I said
thanks Mr Mayor and I guess my comments
might surprise you so
um let's do this in good heart and look
I I'll straight away move that the
position of a dedicated ea uh for the
for the mere be declined no other mayor
in southern region has a dedicated EA
I'm concerned about the cost of 85 000
being inflicted on the community we're a
small Council the council wardian
employs an AI 50 dedicated to you I'm
deeply concerned at the potential
employment ramifications it's referred
to in the chief Executives report it's
referred to as management of change
process and that report
the community would really be better
served by investing a resource into more
urgent areas Finance policy roading
um
yeah being you missed me you campaigned
on Back to Basics and eliminating vanity
projects and I was part of the council
that that uh that undertook some of the
vanity projects so I'd have to say this
role could be viewed as your own
personal vanity project so hence that's
my my motion and I asked for a second
a second lip motion so the motion that
um that this this recommendation is well
the recommendation of
um having a
in executive assistant
um declined so moved by councilor
heisted and seconded by councilor Reed
did you want to speak to the secondary
or you went to the reserve for that for
later on
yeah yeah it's open open discussion on
that motion yeah yeah I'm I'm in my view
we're too small for this
um we also have
um already an aea as councilor Heise had
said and I think
um really she could be a Flight Risk if
she feels that her job is not being
taken seriously and as also councilor
Heise did you all campaigned on Back to
Basics that was one of your main
projects and this is absolutely not Back
to Basics so in no way can I support it
Council learn it file
Richmond fair just checking one which
one you're referring to you worship
yeah we have two guns drawn
um yeah I'm I'm probably uh as the other
Council has stated
um probably some of the commentary
you've given there you Worship in regard
to media and uh obviously you have been
elevated to a high profile very suddenly
and uh there was a huge uptake in regard
to Media no doubt media is just around
um what we're discussing here but it
should be emphasized that the council
has a media section they have media
managers we have communication managers
um if that was going to be part of the
factors that you're pushing forward
around the EA when you actually have a
did it we have a 50 PA there
um I don't think there's any grounds for
it to be supported there and I do agree
with my fellow councilors it is a luxury
item
um our other brothers and sisters
councils around the countryside that
surround us don't have that have that
opportunity so I won't be supporting
that and uh
uh support the emotion by my fellow
Council of High Street
any further comment anyone else
councilor Phillips
thank you your worship um
my main concern is is the section that
you've got 4.1 and your justification
and
and the last comment it says the
dedicated personal assistant not to
share this resource with the chief
executive were others
I have a grave concern about that
because we
hopefully are transparent in all
directions in the living Council whether
it be staff or or the government's group
and this is why I'll be voting no
basically because of that comment and it
really fooled me that it was in there
thank you for that counselor uh
councilor for Lincoln do you hear Joanna
before sorry sorry Council production
councilman
your worship thank you um
I want to make a bit of a statement here
I'm going to have a wee bit of a
rave on or whatever you want to call it
I believe because of your age and
there's a lot of us here at newbies
you may have needed a bit of extra
assistance at the start I know it is
available
and just things didn't quite go the
right way but I know
that you who you have been personally
under a hell of a lot of pressure from
media Etc
and I do back you but possibly there
isn't a need for a full-time
person to help you out but I do believe
the recommendation was part-time but yes
yeah I think there possibly was a bit of
Need for
extra support and possibly better
communication all around the place
that it's my comment thank you
councilor Dixon
thank you worship
um my my concerns about this is actually
the cost because it's not just the wage
it's also there's um superannuation
there's training there's travel and
other costs here and in this climate
when everyone's feeling things are quite
tight that's actually another 0.4
percent on our rates so
um I know that you probably do have a
lot of extra work to do and I agree
um with councilor caveman
that
um that yes you have had some extra
pressure put on you but I just can't
don't think that Council can absorb the
costs at this time
thank you
thank you councilor any further comment
no perfect uh we shall have a vote then
um can I get a raise of hands of who
would like that motion to carry
one two three four five six yeah the
racing motion carries
no he only it was only a comfort for
points
either way the the motion the motion was
carried um and so that that has been uh
declined
um
if I may there is a corollary that then
follows from that and I I would hope
that once the committee structure is
confirmed the chief executive report to
the council outlining options for
providing administrative administrative
and government support to elected
members
would you like that to race it as a
motion into the willingness to
investigate a further date around
government support
um pursuant too that those committees
being formed or
or is it just a side side note for now
I'll be guided by the chief particular
but I think it only needs to be a side
note
um that in terms of once we've got our
structure in place I think it's
um it falls to him to then advise us how
how our needs are going to be met
thank you that counselor
um we will move on to the next agenda
item
uh so the uh adoption of pecuniary
interested interest register and the
appointment of the registrar
so can I please have a mover for the
recommendation that the report be
received and noted uh cancel the garden
and councilor Dixon second
uh and now it's open for discussion
the the only discussion type I've got to
have there is around
uh these I just wanted to make it a note
more than a motion around the
spreadsheet that was provided to
councilors under a general understanding
across councilors and I've also talked
to the chief executive that that needs a
bit of work and I understand that
there's been some work done there with
ICC in that regard so
um while that report has noted it's also
following there'll be an updated
spreadsheet for councilors regarding the
matter
uh cool so to move the motion all those
in favor please say aye
and against and the motion is carried
uh the second one there was uh that the
council approved a general manager
corporate support to be the Registrar of
the community interest register do I
have a mover for that motion
uh Council McDonnell and second uh
councilor Reed
uh open for discussion
so so my my only
um
my only comment on that is just given
the nature of um you know there's still
quite a bit of work here to be done uh
whether we want to point the register
right here and now or whether we want to
push it once we have a bit more of an
understanding of
um of the the register
um and it's and it's ironed out a bit
more I don't know what the general
consensus is around the table
uh councilor Hotel I I would have
thought that we need to appoint someone
who actually is doing the work to report
back to us on what's in the register and
we need a redistrar to do that so I see
it as a a
motion of process not one of principle
uh
cool
fantastic uh let's move that motion then
uh although oh
yeah I think it's been moved sorry isn't
it did I keep movers for that yeah thank
you uh so all those in favor please say
aye
and against and the motion is moved
metal registry names
according to the easiest stuff now yeah
uh so if I get a mover for that the
council endorsed the street names of
um and you have to excuse my
pronunciation here
drive and Kofi place within matai Ridge
residential subdivision
councilor readers the Mover and
councilor mcphail as the seconder
is there any discussion on these topics
councilor Reed um I think it's quite uh
quite appropriate given that matai Ridge
is Black Pine and kahokatea is white
pine so I'm happy with both those
place names
yeah I'd have to go out and talk to the
chief executive I think the the
consultation with with local Evie was
very good on that process and um I think
I think the names are appropriate is
there any other discussion
around the table
all those in favor please say aye
against emotions carried
uh agenda item number 12 committee
structure and governance arrangements
for
2022-225 given that we tabled the report
uh and the inaugural meeting
um I would we will table this report
also
um bearing further conversation and so
no further conversation will be head
there
um as for business uh to be considered
at pursuance of government Information
Act uh 1987.
um this is also being pushed to the next
uh meeting is
um a number of us campaigned on
transparency you're not moving into
um
entering committee I think it would be
inappropriate to do this
um at the very first meeting that we
have
um I've talked with the chiefers that
could do and none of these matters are
Urgent in regards to the conversation of
minutes
um I would be quite Keen to have the
order to look into those minutes just to
make sure that process was was duly
followed there so that just needs a bit
of time so they that will be moved to
um the council meeting and there'll be
no further discussion on that one
that's the end of the meeting we've got
through all the agenda points I think
we've got good unscathed
um so with if there's nothing else we'll
close the meeting thank you very much
thanks everyone